wait this was a frozen pizza I forgot
for a second I forgot and then I took a
bite and then I remembered again I
thought you were too good for your pass
Pizza
[Music]
I don't care how much of a snob you are
we all have a special place in our
hearts for Frozen Pizza heating up a
frozen pie always brings me back to my
childhood but let's be real it never
tastes as good as a fresh slice well
today I'm going head to head with James
Beard award-winning Chef JJ Johnson to
see if two pro Cooks can take frozen
pizza to new heights by adding on
Gourmet ingredients we have two frozen
pizza aficionados as our judges today
Amber Ruffin's late night gig as the
host of the Amber Ruffin show means
she's heating up a lot of frozen pizza
at home and my buddies Scott weiner from
Scott's Pizza tours keeps a stack of
Frozen Pies on ice at all times will JJ
and I find a way to take our frozen
pizza games to the next level only Scott
and Amber can decide
Chef JJ Johnson welcome to Pizza Wars
thanks for having me oh my pleasure
thanks for coming anything for you oh my
goodness so JJ today is all about frozen
pizza and I know you're a fancy schmancy
James Beard award-winning chef and all
chill chill chills it's about pizza what
do you think is the time and place for
frozen pizza so you know when you live
in New York and you have kids you get
you get pizza snobs that's true so my
son miles is a pizza snob and there's
just sometimes you know we just can't
get to the slice joint so always have a
pizza in the freezer that I had extra
cheese to
and then it comes out just right for for
him so you used to using enough frozen
pizza I'm using up a little bit it's a
little different today okay
okay so what you got going on over there
so I'm taking the Roberta's cross I've
removed everything from the pizza
everything look at me everything I took
off the cheese I took off the sauce yeah
because I just want the crust okay and I
want to add that JJ flavor to the
Roberta's crust yes we all know about
the JJ flavor
I made some Perry Perry sauce yes so
this is a sauce you see at field trip
it's on our salmon Bowl pineapple black
fried rice and I'm coming to field trip
we want you to come I'm gonna come out
that sounds delicious and there's some
ginger there's some onion there's some
garlic some plum tomatoes I'm gonna put
some king crab on the bottom and then
some mozzarella cheese so the cheese on
top of the crab I want that king crab to
melt into the sauce
for you to get into every bite and then
the rock shrimp will cook really quick
okay so I know that this pizza cooking
about three to five minutes and the
shrimp would be perfect and then when
it's ready when it comes out then I'm
gonna add on the Parmigiano-Reggiano the
lobster is gonna smell so good
[Music]
cool check it check it check check this
oh that looks amazing
now you gotta hit it with the lobster to
cool down that cheese give me a
restaurant at field trip what would you
charge for something like this for this
oh I'm paying you with the 38.
that really does not look like a frozen
pizza to me and the crust looks crazy I
always look at the bottom of the pizza
yeah that's called the booty and your
booty's looking nah it must be a booty
guy
oh yeah look at that I'm about to burn
my whole face on your pizza
this sauce is crazy 48 48 48. y'all
heard it right 48 48 challenge wise
nailed it chose the right crust and you
made it your own and coming from you to
tell me that it's worth
48.38 and I'm tipping somebody oh and
you tipping I'm tipping somebody this
price just went up
I have something up my sleeve too it's
good but this is crazy what's up that
sleeve don't play yourself don't play
yourself you gotta wait you gotta wait
so JJ I went through 11 pizzas at the
grocery store to try to find the perfect
frozen pizza and I went with the Red
Baron cheese Trio and what I love about
it is that I love a good provolone so
when I saw provolone I was sold then I
tasted the sauce and I was like the
sauce is not bad and then the crust the
crust was decent had a nice little booty
to it look at that booty yeah
so this is going to be our canvas and
you know what I'm gonna do breakfast
pizza or carbonara Pizza when you think
about that hold on hold on hold on hold
on hold on
you're gonna turn this frozen pizza
breakfast pizza that's right so I
already cooked my pizza it just came out
the oven so now I'm just gonna top it
and let it cook it just a little bit
more because we got this raw egg on here
okay but first things first we're gonna
add our bacon and guanciale you must
have read about me you know I love me
some Guan Charlie me too the saltiness
of the guancial I love it and what I did
was I just stirred the bacon around in
the blanchardi fat because you know
because you're cheating yeah you're
cheating because you know then I'm gonna
take my egg mixture and I'm just gonna
like drizzle it in between the cracks
right so the egg and the cheese come
together so I'm ready to throw this in
the oven and what I'm gonna do is since
it's already baked I'm just going to
lower the oven temperature and let the
egg just cook nice and slow and then
when it's ready we'll finish with the
toppings
foreign Pizza just came out the oven a
little garlic a little mixture of
parsley and parmigiana and then we're
gonna put some chives on here and it's
just a little heat a little heat you got
enough for me I have a little heat a
little Heat
and that's it our carbonara Pizza look
at that look how it holds up that's like
a New York City slice right there and I
told you all right here we go
um I love how you added enhancements to
the pizza that was already good like you
took it to the next level this is
something anyone can do at home anyone
has eggs anyone has bacon might have to
go to the store for the one Charlie but
it's worth it that's it carbonara Pizza
this is delicious you like it I love it
well thank you but there's nothing left
to do but go to the judge's table so
we've got Amber Ruffin from the Amber
Ruffin show she's hilarious have you
ever seen her show amazing crazy girl
we've got Scott weiner from Scott's
Pizza tours he's the ultimate Pizza nerd
are you ready I mean I'm ready I'm
bringing a pizza with me though he's so
crazy I'm gonna bring it with me
do you currently have any frozen pizza
at home oh my god dude okay so
I eat the grossest frozen pizza known to
man because it has a cauliflower crust
and so I've tried to live a low-carb
lifestyle why why would you try to do
that just so I could just be sad I'm
gonna stop judging tell me about it it
is bad and it tastes like butts but you
have it why do you have it if it tastes
so bad because bad Pizza still taste
great what's your favorite frozen pizza
so I grew up with Elios and I always
used to doctor it up I would add more
cheese always and whatever was left over
in the fridge I would throw that on
there that was my jam growing up yeah
and then now Frozen there's Pizza in my
freezer for emergencies
which it sounds like it is for you yeah
it's two frozen pizzas hit the table
what are you looking for right I am
looking for a pizza that is
yummy
and available to my mouth no I'm just
kidding I'm looking for I leave for a
pizza that has added ingredients that
agree with the ingredients that are
already there I want these chefs to pick
the right pizza first of all they pick
the right flour when they make dough in
this case they have to start with the
right frozen pizza and I want to make
sure that there's attention to detail
because my expectations for frozen pizza
are pretty low
I'm ready are you ready oh I'm always
ready oh oh
structural issue I'm gonna try to get it
into my mouth somehow that's gonna be
fun
tastes great if you picked a good pizza
to start with this is a tough one I
don't know what brand of frozen pizza
this is do you see the underside this is
like a well-baked frozen pizza and I've
never seen a well-baked frozen pizza
like this
it's a frozen pizza that tastes like
this they couldn't pass possibly have
changed their sauce right because the
sauce tastes outstanding and I'd
remember if I had had a frozen pizza
that had sauce that's good
I wonder
no there's no way they scraped off some
of the stuff and then replaced it maybe
it's just the Frozen base
the weak spot of this whole pizza is
literally the weak crust physically weak
and it's a structural issue it's heavy
in the center it's watery that's its
only issue to me the flavor is there
yeah and the flavor was my primary
concern this is good but I'm ready for
more I gotta agree I'm gonna need some
more pizza yeah let's go for round two
round two ding ding oh dang do you smell
that okay oh I loved him already
this is outstanding
this was a frozen pizza
I forgot for a second
mom
I forgot and then I took a bite and then
I remembered again you can't escape its
history
this has been frozen we thought you were
too good for your past Pizza you know
what brand this is
it does taste familiar and once we find
out what it is it will be a brand that I
know and love this does not taste
familiar to me my only guess
is screaming Sicilian Red Baron yeah
Mother Love Red Baron this is trying to
be a carbonara but it doesn't have the
creaminess because it's been baked so it
feels more like an omelette Pizza this
tastes good I like the flavor of it but
to me the crust is easily the weak link
the chefs are just better than the
frozen pizza companies
both pizzas were delicious we both have
our favorites we're gonna talk to each
other we're going to Duke it out
and someone's going to leave here today
A Champion
Amber and Scott welcome to peace Awards
Scott welcome back great to be back and
Amber we're so happy to have you I'm
happy to be here and get fed
JJ and I we spent a lot of time trying
to prepare Gourmet Frozen pieces for you
that frozen pizza game is hard it's very
hard okay Amber Scott tell us what you
think about these pizzas I
say we love both pizzas we really did
each one was delicious in its own
special way the lobster Pizza has such
interesting topping combination going on
I love the spice in there it's just a
really well thought out pizza the only
issue that it had was some structural
issue of the crust which is tough it's
the one part that the chef didn't make
but they did choose we also had this
carbonara Pizza very well balanced and a
really interesting topping combination
that was that bacony goodness of the
guanciale I've never tasted anything
like this pizza it was absolutely
fantastic these are both excellent
pizzas but we can only choose one winner
and the winner is
three
two one carbonara pizza oh thanks
I tried 11 Chris if you stop the ten
yeah you know
congratulations oh thank you so much
thank you thank you for coming and thank
you your pizza looks phenomenal and was
phenomenal
um thank you guys so much yay thank you
see you next time on peace Awards
[Music]
thank you